[Música]
[Aplausos]
tomada
[Música]
e aí galera com seu show no canal tudo
bem com vocês em 111 alegre pelotas rio
grande do sul dia 1ª de setembro também
fazem show em dois de porto alegre e de
texto em são josé santa catarina ea
galera do maranhão em codó todo dia 8 de
setembro caxias no maranhão o dia 9 e
timon no maranhão o dia 10 não seja com
versões leves a família dá boas risadas
há ingressos aqui neste site o link a
descrição do vídeo e agora vamos ao
vídeo com o assunto é sério eu fui
assistir annabelle dois não satisfeito
em ter assistido um veleiro fui lá
assistir na barry town e o silvio santos
fez a pegadinha da tabela assim a pessoa
nem a pessoa normal da rua pessoa que eu
digo não é ator vai cuidar da criança na
casa e aí a boneca vírus apanágios cara
e aí ouvi essa pegadinha do silvio
santos
antes de assistir o filme que eu fiquei
assombrado com essa pegadinha fiquei por
todo lugar que eu entro agora eu penso
que está tentando pegar de um estilo
santo e no caso de uma criança tio sam
em um supermercado madrugada ou no
restaurante civis a otan que foi saiu
também a mim nunca assistiu anabela em
teresina foi consultada vocês viram esse
vídeo não funciona bem lá no cinema
teresina não sei se misturou com o calor
também de cabeça mas faz com que o
teresina shopping onde o clima para ele
é mais gostoso você tá assim mas como só
sei que a minha depois que assistiu na
belle surtou ficou rodando no chão lá do
choque rodando por olhando as pessoas
falando meu deus a linha possui vamos
filmar coloca na internet é pobrezinho
gritando que eu não tava lá pessoal
tivesse lá sei que a coisa toda
saiu um atrito se um só sapato chute
dessa praga a não era nada passou mal
mesmo assistir ou na bela e vai eu no
cinema assistindo à belle que vocês
querem classe só que eu fui depois que
ela tinha assistido à merda dessa dívida
é ainda possível interesse era eu antes
de entrar na sala para assistir o filme
olha as outras pessoas ela sair do bom
neymar que está regulando vai possuir
não né
vai ficar tranqüilo neocom coisa boa
agora assistem tabom isso oi foi bom
filme tá tranquilo não é pai de jesus na
oi
por favor se a mãe dessa menina é algum
sinal de possessão hoje virando um banco
não pois a bom jesus é bom né sopa todo
bom tempo passar a mão no seu cabelo vai
estar saindo algum bush fricon coisa o
rabo não é uma empresa nada foi roubado
na de demônio ou então
tá bom ela vai ou se vestir e eu fui no
caso não há para quem comprar essa aqui
é a sala 4 b que a cadeira baixa de 9
anos eo google comprar pude mas é mais
massa cara que tu vai ver as coisas
mexem de meu amigo eu não posso ir pro
filme de terror pode ser a porta
brinquedo um infarto então pra mim é a
cor que mais dá medo em filme de terror
só as portas porque está aqui tranquilo
de boa na música te prende tu fica
aquela tensão assim o que vai acontecer
desgraça o rádio só uma porta que fechou
o coração a detenção do chefe que tem
beleza né pra eu no cinema na sala
normal quando soube que está em 544 del
sol vai assistir normal entrada da sala
tem só eu e dois cara foi lá que eu
pensei meus olhos por ligar como é que
se uma na bela e 2 é o seguinte é como
se fosse antes dona belinha um é o
início como foi feito na br mostra como
é que foi feita demônio o pai da menina
tinha um negócio que ele fazia boneca
está ligado à cheia de boneca pendurado
assim as perninhas sabe que gráficas
cortar medo é que o pai da menina
rasgando assim saques ao governo assim
que corta madeira bonito que a gente vai
tentar fazer não consegue você vê o cara
esculpindo na pele com a dengue é
interessante que você fica pensando que
foi que o extremo que o capeta pessoa
vai estar no meninas crianças não
consigo voltar na boneca deles então o
fundo comece uma criança brincando com o
pai eles caminham correndo ea menina
brincando se esconda com o pai não se
esconda já um bilhetinho para a porta
assim a mim contra mim procurei o rapaz
vai procurar ela deixou um bilhete está
perto mas quem tanto é que ao pai deixa
um bilhete para ela não sair do lugar
que estava escondido e vai pegar o
bilhete para a filha vai pegar o bilhete
já o pai em conta a menina tudo isso foi
só para meninas gente toma aquele senhor
sabe que sua esquerda o infarto por
dente fica sem graça por fora
acho aquela felicidade fica tudo muito
bonito carlos pai filha conversando é
que tá criança muito feliz acrescentando
estar muito feliz eu desconfio eu vou
chegar com a criança fala se em crise
você está muito feliz se você é amigo de
algum demônio aí acontece o negócio
crucial que é o negócio que pé pai né
atravessar a rua o carro pega menina
aquela coisa tristeza tal passo tempo
buscará e aí acaso que acontece o cara
tá morando com a mãe
o amigo morreu ainda na casa ea casa
tipos o cara empresta casa com um
orfanato que as crianças não têm lugar
onde ficará o cara vai lá levo um rumo
de criança dentro do ônibus para casa
dele e fico pensando por acaso do
demônio um monte de criança mas isso não
vai dar certo aí tem duas menininhas que
são muito amigas caminho é pequenininha
e outra maior zinha que tem um
probleminha na perna dela ela use um
bilhete na perna dela podendo a ktm 250
crianças por causa do esqui tomar
vacinas tomar a vacina problema na perna
durante a itb as escadas da casa como
ela sobrar só na cadeira de subir escada
cadeira feita para buscar 60 cadeira ea
cadeira faz um
ela vai subir na escada e tava começando
a atacar coisa de subir escadas entra no
quarto ela está cheia de bonecas boneca
que eu falei no começo os bracinhos
cabeça pendurada medo sabe aqueles que
os 4 nunca quer entrar na minha vida
porque antigamente ou boneca merda em
meu nome eu tinha uma barbie uma pole o
balaio existir bolex olhava tudo assim
olha o canal cw e assim recuperar uma
boneca que fala olha eu sei que estava
aberto o pacote que engraçada eu sou
amiguinho falo mais de três frases é
assim a boneca ou coisa feia maria ao
que acontece no filme uma freira ligado
na primeira criança boneca demônio morte
a menininha a actual problema na perna
tá caminhando pela casa escutou uma
coisa caminha tutu eu já ia embora da
itabom só valeu galera tô indo embora
fique vocês aí hamas é a casa nova nós
temos lá não fiz uns amigos na
cracolândia tranquilo vou lá a galera
tem uma galera jantando a luz começa a
piscar eu não sirvo para filme de terror
eu estou jantando advogado na luz começa
a piscar jardim logo satanás é você e eu
conheço todos os seus truques adianta no
brasil está reproduzindo em nome da
mafarra não adianta nocivos a amiga está
dormindo filme e que o problema na perna
aí ela dormir pq senão um bilhete chega
para me ache igual tamanho do primeiro
filme do delegado ela vai caminhando
leva lá na porta o bilhete sai aqui
dentro ela abre meu irmão veio de recife
alegando que o tocador de molho nativa e
beleza que ela faz ela entra no quarto e
não basta só ler o recado de onde seguiu
os passos do demônio também a retardar a
galera do quarto ver as coisas ele no
quarto em uma casinha e umas coisinhas
por de boneca cor da filha o quarta fim
é logo a porta trancada quem está lá
dentro sentada que nem o demônio ela
mesmo satanás em forma de boneco né ela
sente medo à faixa após ela caminha um
pouquinho a porta abriu sozinha ou não
não
não ela vai lá e fechar a porta se
afasta um pouquinho a porta abre sozinho
nesta hora tinha dado um grito fire com
essa pegadinha agora é que ela faz ela
pega um pano joga o time da boneca
quando fechou a porta ela vai sair de
costas que não levem onu levantando fina
ai cara eu li o tomou no cu a burro
tomando com a boca é pra ver um pano com
a boneca de baixo é um tapete de ser o
que era aquilo que eu penso que não
quando sai de si não tem nada com a
algum vulto a luzia amélia sai com o
renato e ela vai se confessar para
freire é isso que tem um raio as pessoas
de filme ela não sabe contar as coisas
que ela se recusou a falar sou burra
chegou à feira 15 é em mãe eu tenho
tenho visto coisas estranhas e coisa
estranha maluco tem que falar direito
não sei como te dizer como se uma força
ruim uma enigmática acabou de entrar no
quarto viu javi da demora da mulher
corre ou bonequinha fé é a tal de
anabela aipa casa do carro cor da pele
ela vê o diabo demônio ele joga o pano
em cima fecha a porta à porta fechada
fechava o demônio vende para a coberta
tela subir sai a coberto de nada embaixo
ela vai falar que tem visto coisas
estranhas para frei fosse comigo é falar
meu irmão não tá ligada eu entrei em um
quarto do hotel satanás em forma de
boneco aceitar nesta garrafa mas sandy
jesus tem porém amarrado num desvio de
um ano saiba que agora eu joguei um
policial por penso que não tá lá lio
veio demônio debaixo da goiabeira da
hora que eu vi um pano com o demônio
mínimo eu falei de futebol de com foco e
eu venho quando eu falei carvalho como o
re kaboul eu devo morrer comecei a
cantar segura na mão de deus e vai ver o
porto santo não ajuda falar vamos
aguardar e peço meu satanás isso milton
acredita em um confronto eu quero ver
seu irmão não vai acreditar já que ela
fala aí não tenho visto coisas estranhas
ao gol
não conte histórias dessas você parece
que não está ligado em jesus tem que
começar mas o senhor você vai se afastar
de pensamentos ruins a amiga dela meio
da mina que tem um problema na perna que
sobe escada na escada porque tem um
negócio na cadeira que sobe escada de
sua casa buscar a mãe quando se esconde
a face do planeta debaixo da escada
annabelle aquela cara sem gum para sei
lá o quê
tiago cara de demônio própria boneca tá
solta por aí começa a acontecer as
coisas na casa aí não dá né tome as mais
velhas aquelas mulher mais velha que faz
bullying consultas amiga mais velha
amiga bonitinhas injetar já está assim
já ai meu deus a administração a isso
moça tá ligado falando já a carne do de
filme todo filme de ofunato interna mais
velha que há quem olhe já estão
conversando debaixo das cobertas
inventando história de terror que povo
de filme assim as coisas merda começa a
acontecer aí ele começa a falar do filme
de terror o iphone vai vim de noite e
cometeu sério mas fala revendedor de
cortar os cabelos eram bom aí sei que
não é que vem mesmo a manhã conversando
começa um negócio caminha assim pela
casa assim mas que não a aids carro e
foi embora e se enterrou na t rowe
substituto no quarto é bacana isso aqui
o meu pai do céu minha nossa toda a ver
que eu cheguei em casa não válidas em
monitor na minha cama toda vez que eu
chego em casa na pele do demônio está na
minha cara e diz aí fiquei que você vai
fazer eu vou procurar um padre foi me
dessem dele vai dar um tapa na cabeça
dela em desgraça fêmea chega lá isso
aqui em cima da cama disse tu não tá um
enfarte na hora não o nome do filme as
tranquilamente a ela vê o fantasma da
menininha aí vai conversar comigo você
precisa o amigo não existe diálogo com o
demônio não existissem chega no quarto
da minha que morreu a menina que morreu
está lá
quer dizer o que o quarto é dela a voz
embora eu ia ver a mídia dizer ok ok
houve um equívoco pela minha parte
agradeço a compreensão e ele pede
desculpa houve uma equipe com ok
houve uma químico aí quando ela pergunta
aí acabou sendo o melhor caminho do
vinho café e vir demônio e sai correndo
e eu saí correndo na minha que tem um
problema na perna vai descer as escadas
de sentar na cadeira a descer as escadas
dessas
gum ela vai descendo na cadeira para
começar a volta do demônio está
esperando aquela coisa chega lá em cima
pai joga na próxima na cae por rebentar
outra perna acabou feito então acabamos
haia no ditado de cadeira de rodas no
caminho mais a mulher levando meu papá
tomam sol a cadeira começa a andar
sozinha de pronto agora desgraçou foi
tudo a cadeira de roda vinheta andando
sozinha a ipo do celeiro ponta menininha
a pequenininha menor do que a minha do
problema na perna vai andar pela casa de
noite e exportá lo o noia né eu vou dar
uma volta e meia noite o que aquela
velha vem a demoníaca balançando na
cadeira de balanço do quarto o que eu
tenho ódio de cadeira de balanço a mesma
balança para duas coisas para ver e
patrimônio só a na copa cama e você vai
ouvir nos pato tuco de [ __ ] que pariu um
[ __ ] merda a imitar a cena que a minha
está na cadeira de rodas cadeira da
sozinho batendo celeiro após rebentar na
porta caiu no chão bombinha papel na zav
o meu filho cadeira andando sozinhos e
nem quer por nossa cabeça é a boneca é o
demônio a ser que eu acho que foi o meu
maior medo vai conhecendo caiu no chão
que ela ficou estava aquela cena que dá
silêncio que você observa em cada canto
da tela do cinema em cada canto dessa
terra procurando um erro tem alguma
coisa caminhando por ali o que vai
acontecer agora os e observando tudo
aquele silêncio você fica pensando na
desgraça nunca gay tony não foi meu
demorou fóton nada à menina a filha do
cara vem caminhando assim que não temos
sabido e mongodb botar a espera máxima
popular porta-se e vômito negócio preta
na boca dela e pro daí para frente essa
menina parece feliz 24 horas por dia por
isso que eu desconfio de gente feliz
demais fica aí a dica pra você
aí vem a parte eu fico indignado o pai
da menina vai lá tá lá a menina japão
quando a pele qual caminho a menina é do
problema na perna que está ferida de
quatro horas por dia ela comece
transformado demônio assim ó mas sequer
assim ó e vira um demônio assim ó ó o
demônio dança break mas assim é o cara
quebro caba todinho mesmo demônio vai só
por cento se quebrando mata o pai da
menina a freira ver todo mundo fica
morrendo de medo daquelas coisas criança
vendo gente morre passa o tempo a feira
só assim vamos crianças está na hora de
dormir
a vai tomando um capeta mora na casa de
vocês quer dormir a minha pequena começa
a enlouquecer vou jogar essa boneca do
post pega boneca sai correndo sozinho
mostra pra ninguém joga dentro do
possível perceber um jogo ou demônio do
poço daí que saiu a somar o chamarei a
feira vem atrás do democrático chave
podendo uma desgra a menina que está
feliz 24 horas por dia que virou de
mudança no break começa querem matar
todo mundo a do dia 4 com a se esconder
quem está lá e esse é o meu dia na bela
lição é com esse que dá medo um pouco
você olha ja ta ltda segundo pai
se você gostou desse vídeo se divertir
um pouquinho clique em gostei está até
com o benfica que sabe chutar foi que
perdi me clique gostei tentar selar a
mãozinha assim pra cima tentar no
computador você vai clicar e gostei
muito de escrever se está aqui do
ladinho que agora está acime puladinho
totalmente diferentes